la jornada electoral como es costumbre
en irán empezó muy temprano a las 7 de
la mañana cuando el líder supremo de la
revolución depositó ese voto y volvió a
invitar a los iraníes a votar dijo que
cada voto era importante aquí la gran
duda de la jornada de hoy será esta
participación que las encuestas dicen
que no superará el 44 por ciento sin
embargo hemos hecho un recorrido por
varios colegios electorales de la ciudad
de norte azul y hemos visto que la
asistencia varía dependiendo de muchos
factores hay mezquitas especialmente
donde se ve mayor asistencia y otros nos
dicen que bueno que la gente tiene miedo
por la pandemia también hay una gran
apatía descontento por la situación
económica y por el desempeño del
gobierno de hasan rohan y otras personas
nos han dicho en la calle que ellos
creen que no vale la pena porque el
sistema es el mismo que al fin y al cabo
la decisión está tomada desde arriba sin
embargo hay a la espera es que tanta
respuesta va a tener especialmente en
las horas de la tarde cuando cae
y la mayoría de los iraníes se deciden a
asistir a estos colegios que muchas
veces están abiertos hasta altas horas
de la noche la gran duda ha sido en la
función de unas máquinas que se estrenan
por primera vez en irán para
contabilizar los votos aunque las
autoridades dicen que ya lo han
arreglado